laissez pas
angers grande aventure les appels c
encore nos héros sont en terre maya au
milieu d'une végétation luxuriante et
dans une chaleur étouffante à la
recherche du docteur chimot et d'une
prétendue reliques et comme moult
explorateurs vous le confirmeront les
aventures à l'étranger commencent bien
souvent par un problèmes d'intestins
thomas c'est pas moi c'est il ya
peut-être je n'ai pas de refi ce qui
permet de produire ce sens bon thomas
prend un moment pour toi nous attend ici
ça vient pas de moi vous savez quoi
ça m'énerve ces accusations j'ai besoin
d'un moment tout seul pour réfléchir à
un plan pour récupérer la relique de ton
père juste prix d'or les produits sont
la cuisson de la réflexion je reviens
iris c'est étrange je ne t'ai jamais vu
assouvir ce besoin et main que
représente l'évacuation des déchets
parce que je suis une princesse et bien
tenez voici les clefs aliénor regard de
maya ah oui c'est vrai il fait quelques
uns mais vous ne prenez pas les clés
mais on s'en fout tes clés à la con tu
vois bien qu'on n'ait plus enfermé dans
un bateau et j'essaye d'aider la mairie
ce sens nous désormais calé cette forêt
luxurieuse et séparation perdent en
battant cartes etc les lie et de nous la
machine à voyager dans le temps très
bien si ça peut me permettre de
récupérer le royaume mais [ __ ] il faut
toujours qu'elle disparaisse rice qui
entend c'est thomas je détecte d'autres
êtres humains certainement des mayas ne
nous approchons pas les autres membres
sont en train d'enlever c'est trop
dangereux pour nous et on le laisse se
faire que seidel on laisse se faire
trucider non bien sûr que non pardon je
n'avais pas compris que le temps a
utilisé la réponse jusqu'au suivant
l'est
de loin ok les dégâts parfois avec moi
au juste la chance est important mais
j'ai un peu peur j'ai eu une pyramide
d'accord on va là bien ok on va à la
pyramide je tiens c'est toujours quand
j'ai besoin d'un trail ce robot du futur
qui ont un jeu mais vous savez faire
quoi de moi regardez ils ont même thomas
en haut de la merde
non il ya trop s'approcher il faut le
sauver la cérémonie commence à regarder
il soulève thomas devant la foule et le
temps d'un bout de bras j'ai pas fermer
les yeux pour tous le décrivent
précisément alors mon ex très bien mode
silencieux qu'est ce qui se passe et ils
l'ont tué 110 mode silencieux je décris
où je décris pas qu'ils ouvrent les yeux
elle même c'est oui ils ont l'air
totalement pacifique ans est allongé
elliot on a peut-être une chance aux
étrangers la bienvenue vous voulez des
guilis aussi un nom non sans façon nous
sommes ici pour libérer notre ami thomas
il est pas prisonnier
juste faire la cérémonie des chatouilles
maintenant que c'est fait nous avons
satisfait les dieux et donc merci pêche
aux boissons gâteaux et pendentifs de
douilles
on lui fait et chatouille presque aussi
bon que mon café
je suis preneur de la recette frais non
c'est pas votre addition de faire des
sacrifices humains avant oui avant il ya
200 ans des ancêtres étaient
complètement fou il sacrifiait des
vierges pour les dieux tout ça mais
entre temps on a découvert le cacao
ça nous a tous détendu et maintenant
c'est chatouille le chocolat chaud
aujourd'hui on est pacifique 1 c'est
fini cette violence d'ailleurs comment
peut-on vous et des étrangers je suis un
robot qui vient du futur et voici thomas
du 20e siècle
nous sommes ici pour chercher une
relique que l'inventeur de la machine à
voyager dans le temps vous a sûrement
passionnant mais non fallait pas tout
dire comme ça oui je veux tu as com et
vous nous croyez
ben on croit déjà une bonne trentaine de
dieu dont le dieu chasseurs d'opossum
alors des gens qui voyagent dans le
temps franchement c'est pas d'un gab
d'ailleurs on a eu la visite d'un dieu
blanc pas plus tard que ce matin super
tu sais mon père béninois lui non car il
a disparu comme par magie il nous a
donné une relique à protéger comme la
prunelle de nos yeux on l'enfouir sous
le temple avec des pierres des gardes
des caïmans natori qu'à regarder la base
des nouveaux visiteurs du cac 40 ont les
visiteurs ce qu'ils appellent visiteurs
semblaient être des conquistadors cool
ils vont nous massacrer et s'emparer du
ping
cool ouah comment ils sont beaux les
nouveaux visiteurs
assis sur leur chien géant et tour de la
table ils ont des bâtons qui font du
bruit des éclairs regarde capoue des
cavaliers avec des faydits comme suit
corinne amis maillard ces sommes sont
mauvais et dangereux
ils sont là pour s'emparer de vos terres
et non chaque femme soit hip hop parano
comme ça descendons les accueillir
vite le cacao et les gaufrettes
visiteurs voici du cacao et des petites
gaufrettes croustillant super bonne
teinte qui gueule toi ô lâche le
capitaine fernandez traduction mais
c'est obligé l'accent pouilles
je n'ai pas cet homme je lui fais avec
son pourri parlez vous
tiens si vous appelez cappuccino puccino
colin sucre vous l'avez dit vous
massacrer des russes vont mourir tu
voulais te dire que la thèse mais c'est
qu'il a oublié un dernier bilan
j'adore ce voyage où hélas bureau merci
tu nous a sauvés sans toi c'était la fin
c'est bizarre ce qui s'est passé j'avais
ni envie de vous demander de l'argent ni
envie de vous tuer juste envie de vous
aider à ça
la buse c'est parce qu'on est devenus
des amis des amis août et elle abuse
mais des amis j'ai vécu une aventure
incroyable je suis parti à la recherche
d'un trésor
j'ai vu ce temple la pyramide ouais ça
que je suis entré dedans et puis je
suivi mon instinct de pirates
il y avait des énigmes à résoudre genre
de statut presque identique mais qui
pouvait bouger
il semble qu'il fallait faire une
combinaison de mouvements ouais et alors
j'ai dû casser puis je suis passé au nom
de la cassine au piège après il y avait
un long corridor qui manquait des dalles
et il y avait des flèches empoisonnées
qui sortait des murs et semblait qu'il y
avait un schéma précis à suivre ouais
alors j'ai tout cassé les murs les
flèches les dalles le chemin à tout
casser
puis enfin je suis arrivé devant une
porte en métal forgé avec des tas de
chiffres on aurait dit une suite de
nombres est à tout casser non j'ai remis
les chiffres dans un ordre précis
c'était la suite de fibonacci quelqu'un
me l'avait expliqué à vox l'été mais ça
veut dire que tu as trouvé la relique de
mon père on va le trait dahouët le plat
c'est un truc en bois rookie coulisses
avec plein de bidules écrit dessus
ouah dingue je me souviens de cela
c'était un jouet que j'avais quand
j'étais petit c'est un calendrier rond
que mon père m'avait donné pour
le système rats est-ce qu'on
s'ennuierait pas parce qu'il ya les
cavaliers qui débarque en corée lee addy
moins qu'un indice sur cet objet d'après
mes capteurs le calendrier passait d'une
balise donnant des coordonnées temporel
divisée en trois parties
il nous manque deux valises et où est ce
qu'on trouve ça nous vite il est un fait
conquistadors sont plus très loin
c'est bon mais calcule m'indique où se
trouve la seconde est liée à celle du
chef de s'y rendre maintenant voulait
des années il amusé je pense que ta
force sera plus utile aux mayas qui vont
devoir affronter un conquistador notre
destination semble très dangereuse
une aide puissante ne serait pas de
refus bon d'accord la buse qui vient
avec nous coordonnées rentrer mes amis
maillard se vous cache pas que les
prochaines semaines risquent d'être
difficiles
elle a tenu bon au cas où celle qui
était pas au bas de faire ce qu'on sait
faire de mieux on fait des délits et ça
nous réussit les dieux sont ravis et on
se fait des amis aux quêtes et juste
comme ça ainsi vous offre des
couvertures refuser les bretons pour
réalisation immédiate elle est salée
le saviez vous les envahisseurs
européens n'ont pas hésité à donner des
couvertures contaminées par la petite
vérole pour décimer les populations
d'amérique
l'épopée temporel ce n'est pas que du
divertissement c'est aussi de la culture
sauf les petites gaufrettes ça les mayas
il n'en avait pas à la semaine prochaine
pour découvrir leur nouvelle destination
merci d'abord écouter le sixième épisode
de l'épopée temporel n'hésite pas à ta
bonnet et à mettre un pouce en l'air et
à la semaine prochaine